1:17 I think I'd time today I got
holidays only one now right cuz we bout
to drink
don't tell your mama
beyond the a new tablecloth for all the
tea I'm getting ready to fill I know
that that's why I can't keep the girl
now why he got three baby mamas because
he always out here in degree they ain't
gonna keep you warm at night now find
yourself somebody on in yard you know
preferably not light-skinned could they
own the hood act [ __ ] daddy never got
along
you know he just say I drank too much I
don't know why he would ever say I drink
too much you get more than one degree
and my own sister have you ever heard of
this new app called the Bible here you
go baby
[Applause]
I'm great you're welcome for the god I
thank you Jesus for this food as it nor
has our souls are mine and I fear today
tomorrow and the day after that God
you think you forget blessings before
the new Bible my baby got now I know how
Mariah feels
you know Winston and I just got back
from Bora Bora it was a marvelous time
her mother she's always been a little
envious of me and I love her but you
know it was never in her cards I
remember us being three years old and
her picking Rose art / Crayola who does
that
what's the girl gonna do you just gotta
let go and let God you can remember my
roommate my roommate sorry dating dating
anyone
no I've been I've been slammed work
between work and school you know I'm
getting my third degree
you know PhD I'm focusing on me right
now
last month I was actually in Miami it
was for this weird thing called sweet
heat it was like all females like some
women empowerment I'm really about that
you know I'm a big feminist I met a lot
of friends got a lot of new friends oh
my god you're glowing have you been
drinking with a kombucha I said I made
y'all some brownies your mom used to
love these don't tell her I gave you
them dawg
what do you mean you're out of kale what
do you have it's locally sourced
I can't do sugar I can't do I can't do
seasonings is there anything you guys
can you know hook up for me in the back
okay yeah you know what and just bring
me a bread basket thing it feels so good
to have money and you see this color
I earned this oh no I need someone to
deal with job and I'm messy assets are
they trifling that I was I can't stand
nothing they dad have kids so I have two
butts not tell anybody you can't join
then you break me and got young children
Oh No
[Music]